here with lebron we took the long road
to get to game five here
over the last couple of days lebron
there's been a lot of reports about
things that were said
that weren't done that were done how
would you
explain what the last few days getting
to get back on the court has been like
um it's great when you can uh put
together a plan
um have action executed and that's what
we've been able to do over the last few
days
um you know with solidarity we still
with our brothers from milwaukee
um under what's going on with their uh
situation that's going on in their
hometown
so we still with them as a league and
then uh
we try to we will not try we put
together a plan
and uh and we had action and uh we want
to continue that so
it's great to be back on the floor but
more importantly it's great to
be able to have a game plan be able to
execute it and then put into action
right away was there ever any doubt in
your mind
that we would return to play yeah there
was some doubt
um but you know when you're able to uh
you know like i said put together a plan
that you feel
that that's very important um both uh
that can change that can change the
you know the landscape of what's going
on right now both on and off the floor
um then you can have more clarity and
myself have more clarity
and every other player in this league
have more clarity on us going forward
with the initial initiatives that was
put together over the last couple of
days including as we mentioned tonight's
staples center now being a voting center
leading up to november 3rd let's talk
about on the court here
you've extended your streak to 14-0 all
time in the playoffs
but you've said your goal in order to
come to the lakers was to try and win
another championship
where is this team in your mind in terms
of competing
for a title uh well we got better we got
better throughout the course of this
series
we knew we were coming into a series
with uh versus a hot portland team
um that was playing uh probably the best
basketball inside the bubble along with
phoenix
you know so you know we want to just
come in and try to work our game get
better and better as the games went on
as the series went on and i believe we
did that so
we have an opportunity right now to kind
of you know decompress just a little bit
um and wait for our next opponent and
then at the same time continue to um
understand how important voting is and
like you said
jared for us to be able to have uh you
know the nba uh
arenas um as a polling site uh for
for uh for a lot of communities um you
know it's unbelievable and
we want to continue that so november is
right around the corner and we all
understand that we know how
uh uh how big that is all right lebron
we know we won't see you on the court
but you'll be hard at work with your
initiatives off the court basically
back to you